The story behind SHARE NOW...
...is the story behind making cities more livable.
Describing car-sharing is answering the question,...
..."Do we really need to own our car or is it better to share?"
Our answer is yes.
We should own less and share much more.
In 2008 with Car2Go, when we started free-floating car-sharing,...
...it was clear that most of the cities...
...are struggling with air pollution, traffic jams,...
...and we wanted to find a way to make mobility...
...more efficient and more sustainable.
We share 11,000 cars with three million customers in eight countries, 16 cities,...
...and we are part of the mobility ecosystem of those cities.
We're believing and changing the way of mobility.
We saw and assumed the usage of the mobile devices...
...will grow significantly.
That's why we wanted to offer...
...the most easiest solution to our customers...
...by only offering the app.
When you want to start, simply open your app.
You'll see if there's a car pretty close to you,...
...pick the car, reserve it, walk to the car,...
...and then you can easily open the car up with the app...
...by confirming the rental button.
This will happen within a few seconds.